a 911 tape shows that Rob Gronkowski was
very calm when he reported that his
house had been robbed the New England
Patriots tight end called police in
Foxborough Massachusetts less than 24
hours after his team lost to
Philadelphia in the Super Bowl it was in
Minneapolis where is your emergency this
is an emergency this is just this is web
Makowski calling and while I was gone my
whole house got robbed while I'm the
Super Bowl shirt I just got that a
police report says the intruder broke a
window to get inside the home it did not
reveal what was taken in the burglary
but Gronkowski and his two roommates all
reported Island items rather had been
stolen he threw me a little bit whenever
when he was very calm that surprised me
a little when he said the whole house
I'm thinking the couches the chairs the
curtains everything gone I don't think
it was all of that but there's some
specific items were taken always
disturbing when your privacy is violated
well knew he wasn't home